welcome to calop a tria a desert town
near California's Salton Sea this is the
city with the lowest elevation in the
Western Hemisphere 55 meters below sea
level and here we've also got a visual
demonstration of just what that means
because that white spindly thing is a
flagpole and the American flag up at the
top is flying above sea level if it
wasn't for all the mountains and hills
between here in the Pacific Ocean then
we'd be wet but that flag would stay dry
maybe we're dry because no rivers drain
into this Basin the Salton Sea over
there only exists because some
engineer's screwed up in 1905 and
diverted a good bit of the Colorado
River in there for a couple of years but
water is steadily getting saltier and
more polluted as it slowly evaporates
and California's got to deal with that
over the next couple of decades but how
do we know where 55 meters below sea
level
what is sea level in theory it is the
average height of the sea around the
earth but there are some problems with
that
problem number one the earth isn't a
sphere I mean it's it's vaguely a sphere
don't get too excited flat earthers it's
a bit squashed the force of its own spin
makes it bulge by a few kilometers
around the equator and when you're
defining height above sea level in
meters that's a lot
so geographers solved that by defining
the earth as an oblate spheroid
basically a smooth squashed sphere just
in fairly precise mathematical terms but
then there's problem - the earth isn't
one uniform lump of rock bits of the
mantle are more dense than others so
gravity isn't quite the same everywhere
on Earth's surface which means there's a
bit more water sitting over those bits
and by a bit more I mean anything up to
80 meters more those aren't small
amounts that could be the difference
between this city being above and below
sea level and to complicate things even
more mountains are big enough that their
gravity attracts the ocean just a little
so during the 20th centuries scientists
and cold war governments start to need a
global reference system for spacecraft
and missiles which were basically the
same thing back then they spent a long
time measuring Earth's gravity the
result is the earth gravitational model
megabytes in size which asks in purely
mathematical terms if this land wasn't
here but its gravity was and if there
was exactly enough water to fill in the
gaps where would all that water sit and
how far away would it be
from that theoretical smooth squashed
sphere the model was finished in 1996 it
is available to this day on a website
that seems unchanged since 1996 and it's
what your phone and GPS use there are
more recent more precise models but they
are hundreds of megabytes in size and
everyone's agreed that now we've got a
standard let's not change it and confuse
everyone also we have to update for sea
level rise whether it's best-case
centimetres or worst case meters so
saying we're 55 metres below sea level
is mostly just symbolic but some of many
things in the world and I'd like to
think we still put some trust in